[Music]
although the suffix tree approach has
reduced total run time and memory for
red mapping significantly
it still possesses a great challenge in
memory as the genome string is huge
can we reduce the genome string even
smaller
how can we compress the information in
the genome to allow efficient multiple
pattern matching
one way to compress the genome string is
by representing the number of repeats
and numbers
for example given the genome string here
instead of writing g
10 times we can simply compress the
information and write it as 10g
similarly instead of writing c 11 times
we can just write 11c
if the genome has a lot of repeats like
this it would be easy to compress
however the problem is that the genomes
don't have lots of repeats like this
another way which can compress the
information in the genome is to use the
burrows wheeler transformation
burrows wheeler transform is a way to
sort and group data
so that similar letters are grouped
together so that it's easier to compress
the data
for example the word banana after
burrows wheeler transform you get the
result n
and b a a because these are grouped
together it is now much easier to
compress them
how does it works first we keep moving
the last letter to the front to create a
table
for example the word banana we move the
last letter a to the front to make a
b-a-n-a-n
we repeat this again and move the n to
the front
we repeat this until the first letter is
at the last position
the second step is we sort the table
starting from a left column and we get a
a b and n if the a on the first column
are the same
then we compare the second column where
b comes before n then the third column
and fourth column
and so on and so forth then we have the
sorted table
the third step is to take the last
column as the borough's wheeler
transform output
in this case the output is in nbaa
note that the original string banana is
at row number four
why do we need to go through so many
steps to rearrange the letters
sort and create the matrix table one of
the advantage of burrow's wheeler
transform is that
it allows the genome strings to be
compressed and decompressed to get back
the original genome strings
for example if we use the regular
sorting algorithm
the word banana will turn into a a a b
and n
the problem with this is that it is
impossible for us to retrieve the
original words banana
burrow's wheeler transform is different
we can reverse the compressed
information back to the original words
by just remembering the row number
there are five steps to invert the
burrows wheeler transform string back to
its original message
first sort the output into alphabetical
order
for example the output of burrow's
wheeler transform of banana is in
n-b-a-a-a after sorting it became
a-a-a-b-n-n the second step is to add
the output column in front of the sorted
column
then in step three we sort both columns
alphabetically
after sorting we add the burrows wheeler
transform output in front of the sorted
column
in step 4 we repeat step 2 and 3 again
until the length of the string has the
same number of the column
finally you will get the original string
banana in row number four
in summary burrows wheeler transform is
a lossless compression algorithm that
offers both compression of the string
and retrieval of the original string
whenever it is needed
[Music]